welcome to this video playing Leyland
steam Lillian Stein um we're from El
Salvador it's an IM 2458 Ricardo no
lemon is Antonio areas ok ok so the
English Defence with e6b 6 and white is
some occupied to the center quickly with
the three parts this particular line
however no is quite promising for black
you've got those quit on quick them play
against the center
hmm
a bit irritated so Trina Troy i think is
right this position and how is it f5 no
really f5 he's going to play Knight to
Knight f3 of course
f5 is weird
hey can maybe just take okay whatever
vago Queen g 4 h3 yeah this is the only
wolf that makes any sense in connection
to what I did before yeah completely
wacky position
rook on g7 okay goodnight f6f try to
increase some the pressure on the center
if he is neither capturing on d5 now
he's got Queenie to check which is some
bit of shame ok let's try to quickly
class along yeah talk about a strange
position I go night h5 what is he doing
with the rook maybe porn f6f f5 f6 Wow
mmm he's just giving it away amazing if
I take it what is happening here
it's a whole rock here probably no one
Queen h1 is going to play what Kingda to
second look maybe but what is the threat
IAM takes King takes and probably Bishop
f5
95 also take an idea 5s that's a bunch
of checks okay I need to keep it close
probably I mean I'm look up a whole rock
so this should mean something but I
cannot cancel this is of course a
problem and I'm down on the clock but ok
let's not spend ages I'm attacking of
three here night c5 now is a temple
probably probably the shot should be
very good move
Knight f6 not really a threat covering
f6 they don't lie to exchange some samba
terrarium of course didn't consider that
I could I go to give the check here no
doesn't really help
she takes a B takes c3 I guess what else
what is he thinking about I'll check
here and Bishop g6 Wow
okay let's cover Bishop h6 against this
chick i have c 6
so it's its retreat him
you can take age seven no check
yeah he's got see some giant warning
don't believe all very happy hard to
believe the ice got even Queen D sound
check I'm can capture it's not only the
taking here but also Queen d7 check
check yeah I'm just material down and
everything black my signs have one of
those games where you know you're just
winning but try to play that in the time
I mean winning after I got the roof this
is certainly not a sufficient
compensation but very try very tricky to
play of course the computer on the
computer just suggest castling short
really I don't believe that ok but this
share this shouldn't shouldn't be too
bad i mean ok maybe taking first on c3
is easy of it and then 95 this yeah this
is all armed all interesting Bishop f6
now Bishop F sixes is easier actually
giving this the king the square this is
important
this is saying with check the system
this is the key Jack effector I can take
it with check yeah yeah this is probably
winning but um yeah this is also wins /
but it's tricky yeah this is Jesus is
lost laughter queenie for yeah it is
difficult to play so in a practicable
game um White has some some chances for
the rook and so it's so pretty dangerous
Bishop f6 is not particularly difficult
but I thought that this will also be
okay I saw this this threat here so I
cannot play any moves like this for
instance um my sins of jack I because
after that I could give a give away a
whole look and it's still not so clear
there may be epic okay Bishop g6 was
threat so this also i covered the square
and yeah that's probably still winning
visual basics isn't it I've can check c6
takes i have the square now hmm yeah
maybe its way in winning but the white
is white the tech is very dangerous in
any case yeah difficult game I hope you
enjoyed it thanks for watching